[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey good morning
what is going on everybody good evening
maybe depending on where you're uh
viewing this stream from it's good to be
back it's gonna be back it's been a
minute since i've done a solo stream
with y'all so we're gonna be hanging out
we're gonna be 3d modeling uh 2d concept
art from artist arthur
mogni magni i i'm probably butchering
that last name the link to his art is in
the description it's super cool stuff
really nice concept art that we're going
to be taking from 2d to 3d i'm going to
be using cinema 4d but you all can use
blender you can use maya you can use
whatever program you want a 3d model in
i also have a link to the discord server
down below where we have this technical
challenge it's the first week
where we've done our technical challenge
because
i was off
getting married i was on my honeymoon
see i got i can prove it i can prove it
i got the ring to prove it
um it was it was an amazing time i'll
post pictures
uh probably next week and uh yeah it was
amazing it was one of the best nights of
my life it was the best night of my life
and going off for a week to maui was i
wish i was i wish i was there
but it's okay i'm with you guys today um
so
while i was gone the moderators on the
crate with clint discord server issued a
technical challenge where instead of
creating a piece of art we're like hey
how about you model this specific thing
from the artist arthur right
and um i'm gonna be doing that i'm gonna
be taking that challenge myself today on
the stream so you're gonna watch me
for probably a few hours here struggle
to 3d model
a really cool piece of
concept art
um if you guys want to follow along the
link is in the description below you can
download the concept image um
and join me yeah it's a good time so
what are we going to be making
let's find out let's see here
so this is it right
we have
this little piece of concept it looks
like a
scanner thing some sci-fi scanner
looks super cool i love it we're not
going to be texturing today we're just
going to be modeling and i want to hop
into the modeling process as soon as
possible because this is going to take
the entire stream
um
there's going to be some challenges some
struggles but
3d modeling is what got me into
cg
in the first place
i love creating things i love building
things and that's totally that i'm not
the best at it
um but that's okay as long as it's fun
and you keep practicing
we'll all get better together
uh what's up y'all i got you in the chat
here
yo we got kc
edwards in the house i'll be seeing you
a little later today
look forward to that
um who else
oh arthur's up in here
sweet
j boss
rococo what's up rococo
sam i know that's you sam j baz in the
house arthur if you are in here thank
you for letting us uh
uh
grab your your your 2d art like that
um it was really cool i kind of got to
discover your art through this challenge
as a lot of these artists did as well
so i'm excited to
to model this thing your art is amazing
i love it we got mr ants up in here
what's up mr ants i'm doing well
i feel refreshed from the honeymoon
who else do we have any recognizable
faces render warrior what's going on
um we got our first super chat
of the stream thank you sir thank you
thank you you do daily vendors but
recently struggling with ideas do you
have any suggestions on how to get new
ideas
yeah
um
i love listening to music that that
really helps me
going out on walks going out on
adventures go hiking
do something that isn't your computer
get out of like trying to come up i
gotta come up with an idea when i was in
maui
we did some hikes and i got really
inspired by these hikes so i'm gonna try
and maybe recreate some of those
places we hiked to i took a bunch of
photos and stuff so
um that actually got me quite inspired
taking breaks gets me inspired
listening to music on those hikes on
those breaks get me it gets me inspired
it's a good time um if
another thing too our weekly challenges
we have weekly challenges every single
week
they're in the discord server down below
you can join us on that and we got a
prompt for you you can actually vote on
the prompt
and
challenge yourself every single week so
that's a good way to kind of
keep yourself well oiled and um
kind of get up to date because
in a couple months here
in a handful of months here we're gonna
have our next 3d community challenge
another big one the monthly one
the weekly challenges help you
kind of gear up
for that
community challenge for the big one
and we're going to start
crafting these weekly challenges to
better prepare you specifically for the
next 3d community challenge so
definitely join that discord server
below you all subscribe if you ain't
subscribed already too because i'm doing
this every other week
um almost i'm almost at a million almost
at a million subscribers i never thought
that the day would come i know we're a
handful of tens of thousands subscribers
away but it's the closest it's ever been
i created this channel in 2006
2006. some of you guys weren't even born
yet which is crazy to think about that
is actually insane we should move on
um
all right let's give this thing a shot i
gotta hop in before it's
before i crash and burn here and before
it's too late because
i gotta bounce i got a friend's birthday
party at like three o'clock
so that gives me a solid
three hours
to hop into this thing
shall we
i think we shall
all right what i have here i got a
background in c4d
with uh shift f2 will bring up your
materials panel
got a basic material thing here bam i
dropped it into color and i'm cheating
i have this diffuse follow-up not the
diffuse falloff it's not the fuse
falloff it's the mixed strength so i can
hide it
bring it in as i need to
um
the reason i say i'm cheating is because
i just
under the color tab
i just changed the color to
the color of my background viewport it's
kind of a janky setup but hey you know
it totally works
for what we're trying to do so this will
allow you to kind of see your reference
the reason i have it in our perspective
view as opposed to a top or side view is
obviously because the 2d art the concept
art
is in perspective view so
you'll see me i'll basically be using
this panel off to the right side
adjusting the opacity and
let's see i got a cube
and a camera kind of lined up right so
you can see we have a camera i changed
the focal length to something like a
hundred i believe
to better or 150 to better match the
focal length of
the 2d concept right
so that way we can kind of
you know see what we're doing as we're
creating this thing i will be doing a
mix of turning this off and on et cetera
et cetera i think you guys get the point
evolver what's up dude thank you i love
your support man thank you so much
i really really appreciate you the super
chat is very helpful it means a lot
thank you so much
thank you good sir
all right jazz vfx you got you got tips
for me you should do right click add
slider and it will be at the top of the
viewport okay right click where
just anywhere
add slider
i learned a lot from you guys on the
stream
uh
right click what you gotta be a little b
a little bit more specific you know what
i'm saying
oh oh oh
add this slider
uh
animation coming up
right click the mix slider
add keyframe add track add keyframe
clear uh
create script
you gotta be a little bit a bit more
specific reset select all add to hud add
the hud
does it have to be right here what
control
dude
that's nuts
yes
thank you i didn't i didn't even know
about that that's so good
wow that's so good okay
thank you i also have on my cube i have
under the basic tab i have the x-ray box
checked
maybe we can do the same thing we can
add that to the hud
ctrl
and just click that that's so sick
i had no idea thank you
you have to hold ctrl to wait where to
go though
oh i have to i have to have it selected
okay whatever it's all good we need to
jump into this
um also just in case i'm gonna have uh
pure f open
and we're going to have
bam
we're going to have this here and just
to show you all what the goal is we'll
see if we get there on the stream but
this is mdk's
model it's flawless
we're going for something like this
evenly spaced geometry
everything's looking really really nice
very smooth bevel beveled edges we're
gonna be doing subdivision workflow
so this is the goal
obviously there
is a back view because we're doing a 3d
view but i'm not going to be focused on
the back except for the antenna of
course
but
yeah we're going to be going for
something like this nice and clean it's
a technical challenge got to keep it
clean
we'll see
how it goes
all right jace jace vfx jazz vfx he said
you can do n plus r to enable x-ray on
the object so
bam bam i like it
it's very good stuff
thank you so much for those tips and i
miss the super chat before we hop in
who do we got
akash thank you are you interested in
work for indian movies cg lead
who knows i got a lot of projects on my
own right now um i feel like that'd be a
huge undertaking
you never know hit me up um
my email is on my youtube so if you guys
have business inquiries
throw an email my way we will see you
never know
all right
let's do it
gotta hop in
enough chit chat
gotta get focused if you guys are
joining me if you guys are gonna model
this yourself on the stream with me give
me a thumbs up
let me see it i want to see who's doing
this so we can uh we can help each other
out
all right my first goal is to make a
blockout
of this thing so i'm going to quickly
all right
all right
all right all right
[Music]
so obviously this thing is made out of
different pieces
nr for x-ray i love it
it's not exact
it's not perfect
let's see if we can move this null
object a little bit more to line this up
that's good
i think or did i do that
um
we want to move the camera
there we go
just trying to line this up nicely
something like that it's not gonna be
perfect but it'll at least give us what
we need to
to line these things up with
maybe come a little bit more
yikes
[Music]
yikes
jeez
i'm gonna leave it i'm not gonna worry
about that
ctrl shift z will undo camera moves
all right let's
something like this feels about right to
me
might be a little thick but
we can always adjust that holding ctrl
i'll duplicate this
[Music]
and i want to get a block out as fast as
i can
for this object
so i'm working on this
grayish green piece here so we have this
top piece which will have some detail
and we'll have this bottom piece which
will have some detail
i believe i'm going to make this
editable
and
bevel this
yikes i don't want to do that
so maybe i'll lock the camera down
under rigging tags i believe there's a
protection
so that way we can't we can't move the
camera accidentally
and let's go ahead and
go to edge mode here
bevels ms
and we'll get that
down to something
like
something like this i'm going to give it
just a little edge there
okay
um
all right we have this like
the tannish yellow right so this whole
thing i'm imagining connects
so the cylinder piece comes out to this
bracket which
clasps on
to this module and probably connects in
the back
it may not connect in the back as well
it may just be these like brackets that
clasp it and are drilled into the side
here
and then you have this hood which i'm
imagining will flip closed to protect
the screen and flip back open
um to this view here
so that's a big piece we got to work on
i'll probably get the handle next
because that's more that's that
will kind of define our shape our
overall blurryish if you squint your
eyes really hard
that's kind of what we're going for so
let's go with that next
with this cube selected if you hold ctrl
you'll spawn any object you want inside
of it
that way it keeps everything
kind of lined up
in uniform
nothing's off axis
and let's go plus
z
we'll scale this guy down
somewhere like that
wonderful and
go to object mode but we can open that
up just a little bit more
something like that
and of course it'll be tapered along
certain points of this thing
nb will get your wireframe mode
let's go eight segments
because we're gonna do the subdivision
surface workflow
mm-hmm
and holding alt
i will drop it into that subdivision
surface
and just make two cuts really quick
so kl i believe is and if you hit q
it'll toggle between subdivision surface
on and off
we'll have to make the cylinder editable
by hitting c
let's see here we'll make some cuts
in line mode
or edge mode rather boom
and we want to solo this
and boom
that'll be fine for now
um
maybe we can do
an r
bam okay let's see if we can do a couple
more cuts
[Music]
maybe there
[Music]
and there
and we'll scale this down but we don't
want it to shrink on the z-axis so i'll
uncheck that and just
scale it that way
well we'll make more cuts we're already
getting too detailed at this point i
still want to
block out this whole thing so we'll
we'll come back we'll come back to that
and make it look nice
um next up let's get the
let's get
i want to get all of our pieces in place
then we go into the detail
this is by no means the right way
maybe it's the wrong way who knows but
it's a way
okay let's uh
let's get this ring in place because i
know from this ring we're going to grow
out
this little
side
little bracket
right and then from the side bracket
that's going to clasp on to
this main module here
so i'll get that
little cylinder in place
which can probably come no it's going to
be a separate object so with the
cylinder selected object mode right
shift f2 will get rid of our material
window there
let's go ahead and hold ctrl
with the cylinder selected we'll make
another let's make a
a tube
plus z so it's facing the right
direction
and we'll scale this down
somewhere in here
something like that
sweet
get rid of the height segments
and
we want to make sure that
let's see 16. do we go an odd number
that way we have this one piece breaking
off
we can figure that out
in time but that way we have this one
piece right here right in the middle
that we can extrude from we know it's
right in the middle there so you can
come back to that
um
it looks like there's another one up
here holding control
it's definitely
again looking at the reference
more
[Music]
cinched down to this thing
something like that
it's somewhere in there
okay
um
we have
looking like in the center of this thing
this knob right here
so i'm gonna go ahead and line that up
holding control once again so if i were
to just
make a cylinder luckily we're keeping
everything on zero zero
but i'd have to like line this up
make sure it's all good
yikes
what's going on
anyway it's also like this i'll hold
ctrl we'll make that cylinder
that way it's just in the center
lined up with the handle i would imagine
something like this
and i'll just make the
there's kind of like two pieces to this
there's the knob and then there's the
base of the knob
so i'm going to
just get this in place knowing that the
knob will be on top of that or in fact i
might as well we're here
something like
maybe this is a little taller
and again i won't really know until i go
back to my camera view and i see how
this lines up but i'm getting this in
place generally because i know this
stuff is going to be here right
it might be a little big but we'll see
we'll make the adjustments make sure you
guys are saving your stuff you can save
iterations too
scanner you can do scanner
scanner a scanner b
um
make the cylinder 18 sides
i don't know why
but okay
i trust
because you've done this before can you
explain why it needs to be 18 sides
mdk
ah
so mdk has been down this road before so
this has a certain amount of teeth uh
okay i see i see
wise words
very wise words
you see yes you see
is mdk
all right
let's see
let's see
for the hood how are we gonna do this
hood
hmm
should we do the brackets first
or should we do
the hood
the brackets okay those might be a
slight challenge
um
let's tackle
the brackets
yeah i was gonna be like let's move on
to this little like light thing
ah let's jump into it okay so
some sort of side view situation um
[Music]
since we're going to be doing a
subdivision surface method i will
probably make a
select this hold ctrl
and we'll make a polygon
we'll flip it
or rather rather
we'll go plus the plus
x
sure
kind of get it right up against this
thing
and now this is kind of where i have to
make things up
so
let's make this editable go into point
mode
now it definitely looks like the top
is is flush
with this box right it needs to snap
onto this thing
it
kind of it comes down this way
and out towards the top
okay
all right let's see about this
hold
ctrl to make some new geometry it comes
up to like
up to here
i'm looking at this point
this is the top of our box right here
right here and this yellow pale bracket
comes just up above
like that okay
i don't know if that's a hole or a bolt
but i actually it's more of like a
riveted little
little hole that i'm imagining this is
where interpretation comes in
[Music]
let's see
it looks like this comes straight down
and then it angles
back
right here
so let's see what's the best way to do
this
so we want to stay away from n-gons as
well that's the goal
[Music]
so an end gun is basically a
more than
four-sided uh quad right we're looking
at quads right now four sides
tries are three
three sides
n gone is
five
six seven eight nine ten a million sides
so we wanna keep it as quads that's the
goal with this i don't know if we'll be
able to do it but
that's what i'm aiming for
okay so let's go ahead and uh
let's pull one of these out
okay
bring this up to the point where we
think it's gonna start somewhere in here
and this will come up
something like that
maybe
and then
we also have a point here that comes
down like this
kind of what this looks like to me this
shape
so i'm going to save this polygon i'm
going to duplicate it
and let's actually clean up
our stuff here
alright this is our camera
alt g will group for you i'm just going
to call this scene
and then i like to group all this stuff
alt g
to group and i'll call this geo
all right
okay this here is our knob
this guy we can just call um
main module
handle of course
and this is our
bracket
the reason i'm duplicating is because i
don't know if this is the right answer
so i want to have a backup just in case
it's not
i'll go ahead and hide that
okay
[Music]
so from here let's try uh let's grab all
these polygons ctrl a
hold ctrl
give it some thickness
which i believe that may have
does that keep
nr gets you off of the
yeah
all right so i'm just going to extrude
this
d for extrude we want to make sure we
have
let's see we want to make sure we have
caps for this
i believe right so i'll push this
let's do the other way around let's
actually bring this guy up
flush
with the module and then
extrude this out
something like that and let's check how
see how we're doing
all right not bad
not bad it looks like it comes up a
little bit more on the bottom so
adjust that really quick
seems to come up just a bit
i don't know if it
grabs it in the back
it looks like based off of the reference
yeah it doesn't go around the back side
of it
okay
santiago hey what's up first time here
and you're wondering if blender is worse
than c4d or it's just a preference thing
oh man you may have started a war in the
chat
um
to me to me it's a preference thing
i've been using c4d since r10
so that's just the program i use
blender is free though so
just because something is free doesn't
mean it's like
it's worse or cheaper i mean unreal
engine is free qixel is free with unreal
engine blender is free and amazing
things can be done with it so don't
think that like just because something
is more expensive means it's better
it may work better for you
after you compare the two
but having
not used blender
i may have been in the program for an
hour or two
um
i am assuming it's just a preference
thing i know people
here's what i say it doesn't matter what
program you're using it matters what art
you're creating in the program so don't
let that
don't let the program thing throw you
off if blender is the most accessible to
you
then hop in get started get going if
that's lighting the fire inside then go
for it
don't hold back
um but thank you for the super chat i
appreciate that and that's a very good
question
yeah each program has its ups and downs
you know
and that just comes
with time as you use it you'll figure
out
things that work things that don't work
and you'll make the necessary
adjustments
all right
this is
not too
shabby now it looks like
it looks like
there's a little bracket piece
here
that
um
all right so let's do uh loop selection
up here i'm gonna hit i think it's mo
that's your edge slide tool and i'm just
going to make a clone of this edge
and it
janked it out for some reason
i think it's stretching it
it's doing some weird stretching stuff
if we limit it nope that doesn't do it
preserve curvature
yikes that's doing some craziness not
good
let's try proportional
so proportional is basically
what was going on when we just did the
loop cut
you see how it's shifting like that if
we take it to
let's see
an edge distance
you'll see how that will actually
maintain
that angle all the way down
and that's what we want
oh boom
i will make a cut there it kind of
hopped on me
bam and i'm going to adjust this anyway
but that is actually pretty darn close
that might be perfect
and i'm going to grab
my now boom
these two guys
extrude
we don't want to create caps because we
don't want an invisible geometry in
there
and we'll push this out
and it's a bit hard to see so
we'll get this slider back in
ah okay
so we need to make some adjustments on
this thing
let's um
open this up
and let's actually hide
the main module so we can see what we're
doing
yeah so that'll come out to about there
we can see we're going way past where we
need to be
so
let's
come into the side view here i'm hitting
zero
we'll grab these bits here and i'm just
gonna push them back
yep something like that
looking good looking good
it's fitting a little bit better and
again we'll hit zero to select all of
those points and we'll just pull this up
a little bit more
we can probably
push this entire module
towards
this main
module a little bit more
or cinch it in perhaps
um it's not too far off
it's not too far off
i think it more has to do just with my
camera angle it's not perfectly spot on
so i think we're good
as is now let's make sure
that we're looking solid down here
maybe this edge needs to come out a
little bit more this angle needs to be a
bit more
drastic
yeah something like that
okay
am i switching to resolve or fusion as
well i've been on davinci resolve
uh for a few years now i love it
yeah it's free
but they also have a 300 version which i
bought because there's some really cool
features like um
i think there's like some ai smoothing
stuff some slow-mo stuff there's a
higher resolution exports
um
a couple effects and plug-ins that come
with the paid version but honestly what
i did
was this was a william foshe piece of
advice is he picked up one of these and
this cost like
i forget how much this thing cost a
couple hundred bucks
and it's like a speed editor so you can
quickly edit with this thing with like
the knob and like
all these guys and it comes with
the full program so i was like hey two
for one let's go so that's a little
little hack there thanks to william
foshee
yeah noise reduction comes with some
noise rejection stuff for the paid
version
all right um
that bracket is not too shabby um
let
us
move on to the other side i'm not going
to really worry about the hole right now
because that's going to be a whole thing
i'm going to get into that
later
but i'm wondering can i take this
bracket duplicate it and use it for the
other side the other side is a touch
different
but
they're pretty darn
similar
and it is a question mark as to what's
on the other side of this thing we'll
just have to imagine what's on the other
side of this thing we can see that it's
like
coming up right here
there's a little bevel
it's a tad unclear but
i think we have enough to work with
i'll start with this side we'll
duplicate it
over to the other side so if i just hit
ctrl c ctrl v
we can go into the coordinates
and just
negative one that thing
and scoot it on over
the reason i'm not using symmetry is
because we're gonna change it it's gonna
be a little bit different
so right now it's exactly the same deal
all right
main module in
get that right on the edge there
and let's see what we can do
to connect
these pieces here okay
so i think the first thing i'll do is
connect the object so we have our
bracket
we have our handle
which has our cylinders in here
let's go ahead and re-group this
alt g to group
and let's take uh
this bracket technically i guess it's
part of the handle for now
and
is this how we want this tube to look
because we are about
to bake things
in i don't want it to be too
thin right so like let's say we make
this editable
and
we grab this piece hit d for extrude we
push it out is that too thin
it doesn't looks like it's too thin
it does not appear to be too thin
so that's
that's good that works out for us it
makes things easy here's what i'll do
i'm going to
instead of
doing this bevel manually
or rather instead of extruding it and
then pushing it out this way and then
pushing it up i'm just going to make a
90 degree angle and then bevel this
later
so we want this to come out to this
point
right here
let's hop into
a side view um
maybe left no it'd be like bottom or
something oh it wouldn't be bottom
what view would it be
maybe like front
i think
there we go
yeah
come on now
all right boom
um let's drag this out
to about this point i'm just guessing
right i'm guessing and let me get rid of
this uh
this image
there we go okay
all right so we get this right up to
this point bam i hit d we're gonna
extrude again
it goes right up to that point
boom all right and once we connect these
actually let's see how is this going to
work for the bevel um
because this is going to come out right
and connect
right up in there somehow
right
and we want to bevel this
ms
but it's hitting these
these points here
we technically we want to bevel this one
too
boom
and boom right ms
and that is not
doing what we need it to do
so i
okay let me try this
let me
do a cut
okay
twice okay
right and then we're gonna go
let me get rid of this x-ray view this
is confusing i'm also gonna
hide the camera hit the first stopwatch
twice and that'll get rid of the
brackets
we'll do another cut here
and i'm going to dissolve
is this going to ruin everything
we're about to find out
boom boom
this is probably
uh what is it mn
dissolves yep so we can dissolve those
points
and then we bevel this
holding shift bam okay ms
geometry
but we'll fix that um
what i'm trying to do is maintain the
thickness of this thing but it's off
anyway
right
back to the reference
okay
[Music]
so we'll have to open up the thickness
of this which means we might have to
open up the thickness of that
to me this is one of the harder parts of
this thing
but we're gonna get there we will get
there
all right we still have those
i just selected
wow that geometry
that's just bad what is there something
going on inside no it's just darkness
here's what i'll do
we're gonna make cuts
and i'm gonna go back
to what we had before before we had
those diagonal cuts i'm also gonna hide
this dang grid because it's annoying
um
filter
work plane world axis world grid
god i always get that wrong work plane
yes
still undoing make sure i get rid of
those okay sweet
so
i'll still keep this adjustment because
i like the i like how the thickness
matches we'll go to our top view
something like that okay
kl that's going to be your loop cut tool
and i want to make some cuts
based off of the reference
we'll do a cut
like here and then we'll do a cut
i don't know
i don't know i'm just making things up
we'll do a cut there
i want to keep this as a 45
[Music]
ul it's gonna be your loop selection
it's like right in there somewhere
and i wish there was an easier way
to do this i should be able to like
dissolve these bits
mn
okay so that kind of worked how i wanted
it to there
this didn't work let's dissolve
all of this and see if that works mn
maybe this will work i gotta get those
bottom ones
hey that did it okay sweet
but it looks like i need to
this needs more thickness
so we need to bring these
towards this point here
and i wonder if there's a way like an
easy way to do that ah
if i undo
and i
set the
axis
how do i do this again you can click oh
the access tool
it's like holding shift or something
[Music]
all right that's where i want the axis
to be for these two
pieces so i could scale them to oh
i'll do the cheat the cheat way i'm
gonna make a null object right here so
i'm hold hold ctrl
dang it why does it not work
should be able to make a null object
right there
this point
ah to mess with the axis this is like
more involved to get this perfect
i'll eyeball it as much as i hate
to eyeball it
i wonder if i could do snapping
bam
i want to make sure it's right in the
middle too
we'll see if this works who knows if
this will work
the idea is just to have a point of
reference for this thing alright so uh
let's go ahead and dissolve
this again
mn
m
n
okay so we have this null object
we want to
move this towards okay what i'm trying
to do is just keep the thickness right
see how the thickness on this comes down
it'll be easier to see from here
this part this angled part is not as
thick as its
the two perpendicular parts
and i wish i could just like scale this
in there must be a way
i am just not
familiar
with all of
c4d's modeling
tools so i want
this
axis to
come to let's make this null object
this is so convoluted
it's the tiny little point and then
you see because if i made it thicker
it's gonna take that with it i don't
want that to happen um fee-wee hey
thanks for the super chat keep it up i
appreciate you um alwyn joseph
your kind words
inspire me
my chances of failure is absolute zero i
appreciate that
thank you for the positivity i really do
appreciate that it does help me out
it really does help me out
thank you
i mean the the the cheat way is just to
move this
by a certain
amount of points here we can just say
like how many centimeters do we want to
do we can do plus plus one you can do
math down here which is cool
plus one okay so that's the wrong
direction
we'll go
minus two
sweet okay and then this one we'll just
find it i'm looking at the bottom right
and it looks like it's going
down oh we'll do another we'll do minus
two as well
minus two okay did that is that better
do we need to go further
yes we do so let's do another minus two
to this thing
and we'll do another
minus 2
to this one
and is that better
yes it's a little bit better
and i feel like we might need to just do
one more
minus one
and another minus one
and that is
probably the fastest way i can imagine
doing that right now
without knowing
the better way i'm sure there's a better
way like i said this isn't the right way
it's not the wrong way it's just the way
okay right so we have that
connecting up to this thing
now we needed to connect to this so
based off the reference
right it comes right up to this thing
and
we'll connect that no problem
here's the issue
it appears that
it appears
that
this
piece is coming out of the middle of
this
cylinder here like just like we're
having it here right
but when we get to this top part
it looks like it's way closer to the
actual
top of this thing right
so i don't know where this is some like
m.c escher business going on right now i
don't know
how it's like
going up
because it's almost impossible for it to
go up unless this is just offset and
it's actually coming out of here and
coming out this like
sideway but i don't know why it would be
doing that
so this is where the creative liberties
come in
i
am probably just gonna roll with it as
is
right here
and go from there
yeah
it's technically be coming out of this
top
one and we don't got time to do that
right now because we got to finish our
kiss close to finished who knows if i'll
finish this thing on stream
we're going for an hour now okay
we want to connect these right so
here is what i propose we do let's take
the bracket
and first off let's connect these
objects right
so i'm going to grab this object i'll
grab this object we're going to right
click the get
we're going to right click and we're
going to connect object plus delete and
that's going to make this one
object and that's great that's exactly
what we want let's take
all of these
faces here
are normals or normals this should be
orange we need to flip the normals
um
we can do that by right clicking and
going to a line we can reverse normals
you are
oh no
but now these normals
oh
all right let's go into side view
deselect
oh this will be a little easier to
appointment i'll hold ctrl
and click point mode and that'll keep
our selection but just the point mode
version i'm holding ctrl again to
deselect
the good stuff
okay
leaving the bad stuff holding control
again i'll go to polygon mode and we're
going to reverse our normals remember
the shortcut try and learn them they
help you you are bam all right so now
this is all looking uniform and nice
great
uh next thing i want to extend this so
it we can connect this properly so
let's go ahead and go into this little
side
view action hit zero and zero zero
what's nice about zero
or rather what's nice about the uh
rectangular selection tool is that it
cuts through
any points it's not just uh
visible only it'll cut through
everything so it's really nice for
selecting stuff and i'm gonna just
eyeball this once again
bam and then just to
do it right you can see technically
technically
these aren't lined up
so what i do
and technically this will this will mess
with my
angle here but it's gonna be so small no
one's gonna see i'm gonna hit t and you
can scale them right and
basically
it's really hard to see but if you look
at these points here they are offset
believe it or not and if i push and pull
this it's going to move them further
apart or closer together but if you hold
shift and snap it to zero
they're gonna perfectly
line up
that is a
super solid trick that i use all the
time
okay
next up here's what we'll do i'm gonna
take the bottom of this
and i'm also gonna push this up
ever so slightly
so that this will line
up
oh good
redo
boom
boom all right close enough bam
right so it's gonna that's gonna it's
gonna lock in now i'll make that cut
again
that's what i want you see that shape
right there see how it's not moving
that's what i want so bama hit that
holding control no we are in point
grab these uh let's go to edge mode ul
loop selection bam holding control
and switch to points and we will
come down
so
we've basically made a little port for
it to connect to made that little cut
um
i'll line that up bam bam bam okay now
we got to get up in here it's nice and
tight we
should
now in theory i wonder if this work if
we just with all of our might
we if we just push this
all of our strength
together
like there so they're sitting on top of
each other i wonder
in theory if i hit zero get the
rectangular selection tool we should
have eight points selected perfect yep
and if i hit uo it can be optimized will
it go to four points nope
it will not
it will
not
let's pull it back we need to connect
this
there's many different ways
we can probably weld it
um
bridge
bridge tool
one two three and
four
and then i'll dissolve this mn bam
now
we're connected we're linked
i think it's looking good
johnny's videos this is live yes live
what's up johnny's videos
alrighty
so we got
this thing connected yeah
but the shape is a bit different
there's a little thing going on here
it's like a bevel
thing
um
what is the best way to do this so this
comes over
but it comes down
kind of it kind of bevels down here
and then comes out again
what's the best way
to do this
ah that's difficult because
this side doesn't do it either okay so
it's a
thing with the concept where
there's some hidden
there's some hidden hiddenness
back in here
where this is where the artist
interpretation has to come back in so
basically we can leave it
all right we can bevel the edge here
um
for the sake of time i want to leave it
but for educational purposes
[Music]
that's a tricky one y'all
it's a tricky one
hmm
i mean this is all gonna be beveled
anyway but like
you know
we're do we're gonna be doing this no
matter what
she's an illusion indeed
indeed
maybe we'll we'll return let's let's get
a version
if we had like let's say this was going
to be in a video game right
or it had to be delivered what some
completed version of this had to be
delivered by the time two o'clock rolls
around which is in two hours from now
i would much rather have
a blocked out version
with a little detail than the most
detailed module right here and nothing
else so let's get a version delivered
so important that is so it's so
important
have a version that you can deliver
before you go into detail
so i
am gonna leave it
i'm gonna leave it for now y'all
okay
okay
moving on moving on moving on
executive decisions
let's grab this
i also want to get that piece over there
how about we do something insane how
about we combine this bracket
and this bracket
into one bracket
connect objects plus delete
so it's one thing now
bam it's the bracket
and i'm just going to grab both of these
and push them up just a little bit
sweet
i'm not going to worry about my bevels
for now because we're going to come back
and do that
with the subdivision surface
um let's see where we're at yeah let's
hop into camera view
not bad
not bad at all y'all not bad at all i'm
feeling feeling pretty good about this
let's get the hood that's the next big
piece that defines its general shape
okay
so let's think about this let's take a
look
at this thing and see
how it's looking what's the best way to
do this um
so probably make this piece here
and extrude it out does pure ref have
like a pen mode or something like a
drawing mode
i wonder
but yeah this little piece here
let's model that
and this can probably be a symmetry
situation
we'll push it out
in that direction okay okay okay
so once again we will hop into
our side view
our right view
cool
let's go ahead and select
the main module
holding control i'll make a polygon
we'll set it to plus x
and let's go ahead
up into our camera cool cool cool cool
and we'll line it up there
boom for now that is fine
make it editable
so we're just gonna hop right in
all right so it looks like the back of
this is flush
right with the bottom of this thing so
this stays here then it
kind of bevel or um
curves up right here
right up in there
and then i'm imagining this comes
straight out
and the top looks like it's angled
downwards
okay
let me think about this so
yeah like this bit
both of these pieces come out
in zero
something like this right
i'm imagining that stays flush
perpendicular rather right angles this
comes down like this
maybe this comes up
but i like this look i like this look
better
and maybe we'll bring this
somewhere like this this comes out a
touch
it seems and we can bring this back
cool and then we have a bevel
right here so
let's go ahead and
make a cut uh just hitting kk twice
holding shift
we'll cut right through that just making
a straight line
and we also need
see one
one one two one two three four
uh
i'm trying to imagine this in my head
here
uh
like if this came down
right and then
let's
see
and then this came straight in
like this
this came up
and these guys came in
like so i'm just trying to keep all
these nice and straight and aligned
something like that yeah
this might need to come a little
this might need to come down a touch
and these come down towards that a
little bit
and now let's hop in to our camera view
and see
how that lines up okay
okay
so we we imagined
what it would look like
now let's go ahead and
try and line it up to this thing
call this the hood
mm-hmm
i'm gonna get rid of this point for now
which turns this into an n-gon but we'll
turn it back
uh mn
yeah we dissolve that
and we can
where is it uh not disconnect where is
it
dissolve melt
collapse
i mean backspace backspace
that's what we want
this kind of comes up
all right so that's kind of okay that's
that's
fitting
our reference
which makes it look like this and this
shape looks pretty sweet i'm not gonna
lie um let's bring our stuff back in
that's pretty sweet yeah
okay
awesome
and let's go ahead and make a cut
just to
get our shape back
boom
looking good
looking good
all right
thank you all for uh
for joining me during this i i really
appreciate it
um
so
are you guys following along thumbs ups
in the chat if you guys are modeling
along with me
or if you modeled this yourself for the
weekly challenge give me a little smiley
face
that way i know kind of
what's going on you know what i mean
um
that's all that's all we're getting back
into it
all
let us see
let us take a look
um
[Music]
okay what's next we need to extrude
this bad boy
so
i think we're gonna get up in here
we're gonna select these edges
or uh faces rather and we're gonna just
get nice and flush up against this thing
and we're gonna hit d and we're going to
[Music]
create caps
we're creating caps
we'll extrude it out
about the same length
as the bracket piece
eyeballing it
[Music]
we want this shape
right
here
we want
this
plus this
cut into this so we could try m o
and you know what
yeah okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay
many different things many many things
all right so let me select those three
mo and try and drag it into where's that
thing but you see how it starts getting
all
let's solo it
we don't want
it to do that we just want it to do its
own thing so proportional we try fixed
distance which
wait
that works
beautifully
i think
i think that works perfectly that's
exactly what we want
yep that's exactly what we want fixed
distance yes for the win all right let's
just make sure that thickness is the
same as that
we can maybe go a little further right
there
okay that's not bad at all it's not bad
i'm getting excited okay let's uh
grab these
we're gonna extrude these we're not
gonna do caps
because when you do subdivision surface
check this out look what happens so
without caps right this is the right way
this is the right way we're gonna
extrude it boom
we might need to make a cut here
you know what i'm i'm just gonna
i'm gonna call it
we need
to do these on the outside that's why i
was like so many things so many things
to think about
man
let's try a thing let's grab these
wait why is that
oh wrong tool wrong tool y'all
shift click
bam
bring that in yeah okay let's try that
again
just like that
on both sides wonderful that's what we
want
and then we want to
kkk bam bam snappy snap
same on the
booty
sweet okay so
back to that example
we want to extrude these yeah
over to this side right for the hood yup
yup yup got it
so if we do that
and we extrude it without caps let's do
the bad example first
let's create caps
boom if we go inside you can see there's
that there's a wall there's geometry
blocking
there's geometry inside here
and if we put this in a subdivision
surface
it's gonna oh wrong one
it might do a weird thing is it doing
this weird thing i don't know let's make
some cuts and see
it's not doing the weird thing
oh maybe it is doing the weird thing it
is doing the weird thing you see that's
slicing it right down the middle like
that or like why is it doing that super
harsh cut well that's because
we have that cap on the inside
so if i undid all that
and we extruded it again
i'm hitting d for extrude tool you can
also right click
and find the extrude tool
let's
uncheck create caps this is the right
way all right we'll push it out
and then now when we throw in a
subdivision surface bam it's acting
normally
we get that soft edge it's not pinched
so you'll be careful about caps and not
caps because
it took me a while to figure out why the
heck it was acting that way and at this
point it's like okay there's there's a
there's geometry inside of my geometry
we want it to be hollow all right so
let's do this with symmetry shall we so
we'll take this point
we'll extrude
to the zero zero
mark
boom
all right we have to eyeball it
right in there
and then let's go ahead and grab the
points
select all those points
and we should be able to
should be able
uh if we hit w let's see hold on
wait a second
why is it all off like that
why is it off like that
what the heck
is it
that's weird
i hold control was it will it do that oh
wow so a bevel sets it off
like that let me show you guys that one
more time so i'll do the bevel you see
how it goes off it's not it starts
getting off center for some reason
but if i hold ctrl and just make new
geometry it'll stay centered
oh wait a second
i'm just noticing this
that's not good so
we need to fix this
with our little secret boom all right so
we're going to select all these on this
side we're going to hit t we're going to
snap them together holding shift to zero
do the same here all right this this
trip this trick this little tip is
coming back
bam
and looking at the chat now we got a
number of people modeling with me
and we got some people who had did this
challenge in the past so that's cool
heck yeah i'm glad i'm glad you guys are
hanging in with me
okay
so we just we just kind of um
straightened this thing out
right let's line it up again
and now in theory if we do this bevel or
this extrude rather
it should extrude straight yeah it's
working properly now
i'm glad we caught that early on
i'm very glad we caught that early on
okay so we want to center these up with
zero zero
right
so
if we set our coordinates to world
they're set to object reference if we go
to world
we can
zero out
its x value so that when we hit the hood
with a symmetry
uh
are these modifiers technically
i don't know the exact name
where where are you symmetry i know
you're in here there you are boom it's
just on the wrong side
we got a philip
oh it's a i see i see i see it's going
off of
the axis
so we need to get the axis on zero as
well
for the whole object so we go object
mode we can see our axis is here we want
it to be on the x axis so if we go to
the axis center tool
which you can find by hitting shift c
typing axis center yeah
boom and i got it pinned up here because
you know i use it all the time
let's do
uh auto update there we go i just slid
it all the way to the far point of the
model this will take it
to where the model
reaches its limits right so we just slid
it to the far
minus 100 percent of this model and i
know it's lined up on zero zero because
we typed it in
it will execute it boom yeah done now if
we hit the symmetry
it'll work perfectly and we can just go
ahead and
make that
uh you know i'll leave it i'll leave it
for now
because we'll we'll come back
another thing too if we set this to a
subdivision it you saw it's all janky
that's because there's geometry inside
once again
so
that is simply because
we have a little cap here so we just
need to delete that
boop
and now it'll
and i'll do it properly
cool
hey not too bad huh not too bad not too
bad
we got a super chat oh my goodness
hans houser crushing it with the super
chat thank you sir
much appreciated very generous view
my outfits are on point
not gonna lie hey
thank you so much i got this shirt
in
birmingham
uh uh
jeez i got it i got it in birmingham in
the uk
um
it's a i don't know we've got some video
game stuff japanese characters on it
looking a little bright here let's turn
this down
i was in london
now i was in birmingham for uh
some convention i forget what what
convention
long story i got the shirt
on the other side of the world that not
important back to it thank you for the
super chat i really appreciate that
oh we got double goodness gracious man
thank you so much thank you sir
wow
very kind of you thank you thank you
we got faux 20 people up in the chat
today
looking good
looking very good
what was i doing in birmingham i was in
not alabama not alabama
five hours out outside of london
that birmingham
it was called like insomniac or insomnia
convention or something
it was the funniest thing guys oh this
this story is hilarious i gotta tell the
story
so i went with this company called three
black dot good friend of mine used to he
he owned it he used to uh work or as a
co-owner and um
they they flew me out
to be at their booth to do signings
and their brand three black dot is um
it's a bunch of gamers it's full of
bunch of like let's play gamers and
streamers
mega uber popular
insanely popular
and i'm just i'm just me
like i make short films
this was maybe this was like four years
ago five years ago
and they're like yeah we'll fly you out
i'm like are you sure like i'm down like
fly me out absolutely i love traveling
i'm gonna pay for a ticket let's go
you know big old big old convention
center
um
you all know it's e3 vibes comic-con
vibes right
and
the booth is huge
they have me
set to do these signings
alongside these uber popular
let's play uh streamers right
the lines are massive they're wrapped
around the booth
and i'm sitting at the end of this of
this table
with a couple other guys i think
i'm trying to remember who was there i
don't know if it was markiplier or like
you know a bunch of other you guys get
the point right
and people are going on the line
and they're like oh my god they're
freaking out about their favorite
streamers right and they're like oh my
god this time my shirt like they have
their shirts and all their inside jokes
and they're like doing outright and then
they get to me and they're like
nice
and this went on
this went on for a full day
a full day and i had like little posters
i think i had like carbon warfare
posters and people were like
i think i got like two or three pity
buys where they were like
oh like you could feel the awkwardness
like they just wanted they didn't know
who i was but like that's kind of cool
sweet no it wasn't even it wasn't even
merchandise it was signatures it was
signatures i was signing the posters
giving away
and people were like
who
are you
i'll take one of those i guess
there was so it was so awkward it was
like
going to it like doing a signing with
jackie chan
and and you're just like who are what
are you doing here
um
so i started just drawing everyone in
line i was so bored i was like just
drawing everyone while they were in the
line
and they would come by and they would
see their drawing they're like oh that's
so good
and then they would just go on their way
and i was like
at least that's like more of like a
positive reaction
yeah that was that was enough so that's
the convention where i got this shirt at
um
good times good times back to it
oh
it was a funny story there's a good good
stuff all right so we got our hood let's
get our antenna i think that's next for
us so we have to figure out how to
attach this thing um
definitely
a cylinder
that's tapered down so
let us do a cylinder
or rather no it's a cylinder
let's not
let's not get ahead of ourselves it's a
cylinder
um
let's go ahead and drop it to
zero height segments
we can do eight
i'll just keep it at 16 for now
whatever
um
hop out of the camera
and where did my slider go
there yeah there we go
let's get rid of that for a second
drop the radius get it over to the side
there where it belongs
sweet alright
so
oh it's connor
it's connor oh and it's papaxo what's up
epoxo
how are you doing
good times heck yeah good people in the
chat
connor this was all you're doing
this was your idea
it's a great idea i like the idea of
technical challenges
okay
um
[Music]
let's figure out where it needs to cap
out at right
so let's bring our guy back in
oh it's kind of doing a thing where it
goes off
to the right side it kind of looks like
a modem let me see hold on
it's a bit like my internet that i just
unplugged so the stream is going to die
in two seconds but um
basically it looks a little bit like
this right
no i'm just kidding we're good
and it kind of like goes off to the side
a little bit
but this one looks like it's
modeled in a way
that's not coming straight off the back
it's not uh
let's see if i can demonstrate for y'all
it's not coming straight off the back of
this thing
it's kind of coming out right it's
coming out and then going up so i have
to figure out
what that looks like i have to kind of
make it up
hmm
okay
so let's move this over here right
bring it up
and
let's
give it eight
sides we'll throw it into a subdivision
surface
and let's just
see here let's see
so
i'll also save a new version
scanner
b um
q will toggle back and forth
and before i make any cuts i
want to
taper this thing down yeah
so i'll make the cylinder editable
and
these are just tapered down about so
maybe a little hey
maybe a little thicker
and we get to a point where like
somewhere
somewhere up in here
it starts to curve around
uh
okay grab that
probably like somewhere
somewhere here
it starts making a move for the center
so if i control drag this out
this starts to get
tough because
let's see i could come down like this
and and it tapers too
comes to like
does one of these things and that's
actually not the worst
it's not the worst okay
kl we're gonna make a loop cut
we want to get real nice and choppy bam
nice and
even more so
see if we can't really slice it
oh wait i'm just doing a weird thing
hold on let me change it back to
proportional
boom boom
[Music]
something like that and then i'll get
the top two at this point
so it looks normal
and then down here it um this is when we
have to start making stuff up because
let's go back
to our camera view
come on now
so it's looking close you know um
so we can drop that down a little bit
further that's great good to know good
to know hit zero
points and we'll just push this down
yeah just like that that's good
and it kind of bulges out a little bit
actually
it's not
super straight so i can i can grab these
we can scale them
up
it's because my z was locked oh no
it didn't really hurt us in this
situation but i'm glad i just realized
that bam
and let's
open this up
as well
a little thicker and then i'll make a
cut right here
and just kind of
open it up just a little bit maybe slide
this down
to follow the shape of that a little bit
more
yeah it almost has some like roundness
to it it looks like
but maybe that's too much roundness
yeah maybe maybe that's a bit much
so we can undo
that last part
that's good for now that's good for now
so that's not bad actually um and hey
while we're at it let's make that little
cut
in there
oh you know what's weird okay you know
what's weird is that our hood is
obscuring this slice which it shouldn't
be and it could be an angle thing
but
it might also just be our hood is in the
wrong place so let me take another look
at the hood really quick
um
so we'll go to our geography our
geometry
nr
ah
okay okay so when we extruded it
it went too
far all right let's see
let's go back to our hood
and yeah i think we just extruded it too
far
very small amount actually that's i feel
like
it's close it's really close i might
have to cheat it a little bit
wondering if this hood can or the uh
antenna
which i'm probably spelling wrong and
antenna that's probably spelled wrong
for sure that's definitely and
tina
how they expect antenna antenna
that's a weird word an antenna
anyway not spelled right whatever um
we can push it out a little bit more
just kind of make up for it just a
little bit
i'll buy that
yeah it's not gonna be perfectly aligned
to our reference
so it's chill to go off book just a
little bit in this case for the specific
situation let's make those cuts in here
i'll get rid of this one we don't need
that one right now
but i do want to make
these cuts bam
one and two okay then we're going to
take that
and
[Music]
we'll push them in
they go in quite a bit it seems
and it looks like it almost
tapers
in a touch
just a little bit
[Music]
boom
and
boom it's pretty soft
i feel like it needs to
go in more
there we go
yeah something like that
we can adjust it as need be
but that's not bad at all
we have our antenna
i'm not really too concerned about the
back right now
[Music]
all right
what's next so
[Music]
the handle we gotta do some detail work
on um we can
we can block out the
trigger potentially
next um
we could also i mean we basically have
everything locked in i think the trigger
and this little like light is the last
thing we need
so let's start with the light
and we'll go from there
okay man i don't think i'll be able to
finish this thing on stream i'm not
gonna be able to do like production
quality on stream here uh
but let's keep moving shall we gotta
keep moving
so here we want we want this cylinder
right
on this edge
and i wonder is there a way
to like pop this out so if i do um up
that's gonna break this piece off
disconnect i believe up
is disconnect
no that's you d
it's like break up i think
is the name of
the tool
why can't i find it it's probably in
here oh split split
that's how i remember it break up up
that's the um
that's the shortcut so
maybe if i so you see how the axis
changed
right and if i hold ctrl and make a
cylinder
ah dang
that's because let's see
boom cube two
we want to center the axis
to cube
two right so
we reset and execute
yeah yeah yeah
but if i do like a 45 is this for is
this exactly 45 it may not be exactly 45
but i think it just happens to be
then now that our axis is lined up we
can hold ctrl and make that cylinder and
it's going to be perfect right
plus x yes and we'll scale this down
amazing
and we'll call this uh
light
[Music]
yes in deed all right so we'll just kind
of get that in place
and we'll get a cylinder in place
another one i'll just control drag this
up scale it down
open it
looking at the reference on the other
screen here
kind of get this
locked in
and then
well technically uh you know instead of
a cylinder let's just
let's go with the the pill
where are you capsule
it's gonna be better that way
the curve will be perfect
yeah and we'll get in there
and make it all nice right so that's
that in place let's make sure
it kind of matches generally
with that yeah yeah based off of my
reference i'm looking at right here
it seems to be right i think the capsule
might be a little big
something like that cool cool and then
let's hit the uh
the little switch
this little button
right here
for that
let's get some cubes in place
first and foremost so i'll select the
cylinder and hold ctrl
let's get this out of here
call that trigger we're actually gonna
group it
trigger cool
get that up there
bam
bam
bam
and it looks like it goes
beyond
it's doing a thing where like
artistic this is the artistic
interpretation here so this yellow
matches up with this gray and it looks
like the red is a side switch or
something and then we have this cube
so let's see
that's something like that
and we have the red
[Music]
also in there but we also have like a
trigger so i don't know
i'm just guessing at this point
something like that
something like that
yeah
okay
um and let's make sure the knob
is where it needs to be
looks like it needs to be a little
larger a little flatter
something like that
cool
okay
okay
we i think we officially have
our block out um maybe minus a couple
little screws and stuff
which
i'll just throw that in really quick on
the side here
and grab our bracket let's make
a cylinder
plus x uh huh
[Music]
something like
what's gonna hinge
on this thing
we want it to actually work
right so if this hood pivots from that
point
it should in theory close over the top
of this thing but i don't know it
wouldn't work unless it's like up here
but it has it back here that's fine
that's just running through the whole
thing
[Music]
cool
all right where to go from here um
hmm
just cause i want to know
what this thing looks like if i render
it
uh
let's do
a plane
boom and
or rather no forget the plane
let's just set a little little octane
thing up so let's do
octane
glossy material
what the heck
there we go
geometry
cool cool uh let's get the live viewer
enter the scene and
you're gonna crash on me no it will not
amazing
oh wait now it's gonna crash
hey
good times
good times
[Music]
what
thank you papaxo keeping it real
uh let's try and open it this way
nope another crash
well that's not good
see you marwan thank you for stopping by
appreciate you was it the crash that did
it
it was the crash wasn't it
how about we open recent project
there we go
let's try that again shall we
come on
thank you
save a new one scanner c
i want to make a
octane
sky
i'll make two of them one of them will
have an hdri the other will just have
the background okay so the bottom one
will be the background that's going to
be a visible environment which will just
leave it to black right the top one is
when we'll load our hdri this was
actually on the server
we're supposed to light it with this
and
let us
hide these
from the viewport we don't need to see
those
switch to path tracing we'll lock it
we'll set it to 0.5 and render
all right so this happens sometimes you
got to go to the hdri click it and set
the color profile to linear
nice it's not bad um
[Music]
nice i like that and then i'll just
adjust the material a little bit so it's
not as glossy
up the roughness
all right so this would be like the
deliverable version if we if we had to
deliver right now this is at least a
version at least it's some sort of
version that represents its shape
and if the buzzer went off right now
then at least
we would define what this thing is with
what we did in the last
two hours roughly so
i have about an hour left
to work on this
so where do we want to focus our energy
we
like my my gut says the handle
and the screen i think i actually i
think the screen is more important
because
that more clearly defines what this is
the handle obviously that's a handle
but but what is this thing
there's a monitor on it i think that's
the last thing we're missing so let's
focus on the monitor
and we'll get some detail work in the
monitor
and we'll see how much time we have from
there
i don't think i'll be able to finish
this entire thing on the stream but it
is what it is
yeah crt screen let's do it let's do it
yeah
cool
all right i'm feeling good about this
it's not too bad
if i spent you know another
if i spent all day on this
i could probably finish it maybe two
days would would be nice
yeah cap the handle
hit it with the screen
i'll feel good
okay
again for those of you guys stopping by
this is concept art by the artist arthur
magne moog
i'm there's no way i can be pronouncing
this last name right i'm so sorry his uh
all of his links are in the description
so definitely check him out he has a
really really cool stuff
um he's a great concept artist i love it
amazing
okay
night cow thank you i got this i got
this yes
okay um
let's work this monitor in shall we
all right so
this is gonna be tricky
this is going to be
tricky
all right
solo this thing
and
just in case i'll make a
duplicate
let's clean this up a little bit it's a
little messy
we got our main module
cube
cube uh let's bring this back
this is our light no we don't need that
cube anymore that was a reference cube
that is our light yes indeed that's our
main guy okay
that's fine
all right so
how am i gonna do
this how am i going to do this
the first thing i'll do is symmetry uh
we'll make it editable
hold shift
delete it
make sure the axis
is still in the center yeah holding alt
we're gonna throw symmetry on it
awesome okay
so that's good we got our symmetry
um
i'm the only thing i'm worried about are
these little like
these holes up here
these are terrifying for me
absolutely terrifying for me
right so we got that yeah
and i could easily just
you know grab this and
that's two p how do i how do i do this
um
hmm
[Music]
i feel like i'm going about this the
wrong way right now
if i
started with
a polygon
i make it editable i cut it in half
we hit it with symmetry
we bring this uh
up
here we bring this out here
we
make
a couple
cuts
here and here
and get rid of this bit here
that way
when we throw a
subdivision surface on this
lots of grunting and
okay
that's actually not half bad
now it's better to find the shape here
just open this up a little bit more
okay
so now like
yeah this is this is just tricky this is
gonna take me the rest of the stream i
feel like
from here let's see we
because we want to inset this
ah so tricky so tricky um
let's see uh mw
and
we just want it
we don't want it in the center
for this i might actually just bake the
symmetry down
get rid of that
and something something like that
ah this is tough
we'll cut it again
and get our symmetry back
and see if we can't clean up some of the
geometry
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
again this is mdk's example
so beautiful
so well done
goodness gracious
mdk how long have you been modeling
and where did you learn from
and by the way mdk here in the chat is
uh uc
apologies apologies
yeah this is this is beautiful
everything's evenly spaced out
ah it's so perfect
so good
so good
master class right here
right super clean
mdk you need to be doing this stream
dude
all right
20 years of modeling yeah that's
there you go
drew what's up thanks man i appreciate
it
appreciate it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
one step at a time here
one step at a time
okay so we need to make some cuts yeah
boom
boom
and we want to
square this off so
i'll make a cut here
bam so that's nice and square i'll do
the same
here as well
boom
and boom
it's not bad
it's not bad
the geo could probably be cleaner
this corner is a little funky what's
going on here
oh it's one of these situations
all right so here's before that's before
[Music]
wait what is that
[Music]
why are these black lines still here
that's super weird
should be able to just do that cut
and then dissolve these guys
weird
[Music]
yeah that's weird i don't know why
it's doing
oh wait a second that's strange okay
so that's correct
but when the symmetry comes along it
screws it up that's so weird
so
i think i need to just redo the cemetery
what
weld points
why is it doing that
it doing some funky like
or do those lines not actually exist
oh man i'm so stumped
is it just not at zero zero
are these not light oh what is this
that's it
ah but i think i needed
those pieces
i don't know how this ended up over here
though
that is weird
darth invader what's up did i watch new
episodes of love death and robots i did
actually um
i did
i saw episode
three the one that y'all were saying was
like the render challenge which i could
see how it's very similar but there's no
way that i don't think they
they saw the render challenge and then
did that because
i mean you're dragging someone it's all
part of the story she's dragging
the other pilot
through the wasteland
and like
that just happened to work out for the
story right
and there's only so many shots you can
capture of someone
pulling someone through the wasteland
so
it just happened to
really look like it which i thought was
really cool
but i don't think it was intentional
and then i saw like the the rats one
where the guy like
got the rats out of his barn and the
final episode
the last episode that that was
incredible really liked that one
okay
all right um
let's get a move on
so i want to cut
like a little screen
sliver thingy in here you'll see what i
mean in a second basically i'm just
going to take this and extrude it
i'll go a little bit i'll go a lot and
i'll go a little bit
and then i'll do one on top of here
that way there's like a little seam
what on earth
who on
get out of there
get out of there
yeah
sweet all right done
not bad
not too shabby okay
now let's connect it to the greater
piece
how are we gonna do that how are how on
earth
are we gonna do this
let's bring it back
i'm gonna make a little executive
decision here and just kind of
pull these guys back
one two three four and just kind of
whip push those back a little bit
just like that cool cool
um
now as for this cube
[Music]
what we can do i'm going to try and do
it just from this screen
see how this is gonna be possible um
wish me luck
grab all the sides here
and
extrude it out
we're going to go ahead and line up our
our center bits right so
hey
we'll get them lined up on zero zero and
then we'll of course zero them out here
bam all right so that's good right
i'll do the same here
i'll line those up and
this needs to be lined up
generally yep it works
sweet
um
this is looking a little crunchy up here
but i knew that this was going to be a
thing
all right what's the best
what's the best way to do this
[Music]
i wonder if this is where the tries come
in i wonder
hmm
okay i'm gonna try and line it up to the
cube
that we have
make sure the proportions are correct
sweet all right
so i know those are my boundaries um i
think i just need to get
a cube
up in here uh or up a polygon let's see
if i
all right all right all right
try making a polygon let's get it
up in here
[Music]
and let's do connect plus delete
bridge tool that's what we want
hmm
that still has tries um
what's the move on this
hmm
the problem is i just don't i just made
it smaller i made the problem smaller
i'm trying to figure out what's the best
way to get rid of this
because i don't want to
have an n gone that's a five-sided
situation
uh
oops
get
like if i do
see
all right so it was in my ear what do
you say soto
let's see first i gotta get this
boom
yeah that that works
that works
now i gotta cut a hole out of this nah i
i
jeez
all right
that's not bad
that's not bad
um let's make
wait a second are these truck
it's all good
it's not really but it's all
good ugh
it could be better
i could be better
but you know it's okay
[Music]
it's gonna be all right
all right let's get rid of this
okay
and let
me
grab all the edges
do
[Music]
and we'll go in like this
an extra inner
a little bit more
i'm just trying to find a way to like
section this off
and then blend it into the cube
okay that is not the
worst um
though i do feel like
it's a little small here and it needs to
come up
[Music]
hmm
what
poop
get
hey
[Music]
goodness gracious
unless that's making cuts
i'm making unwarranted
cuts
that's so hard to tell now
okay
we're managing
uh
and then i want to take this over
uh i see what it's missing actually it's
missing the seam
this is invoked man this is involved
it's missing this
seam here
so get rid of these guys
get rid of those guys
these need to be sharpened
who knows if that
oh man
what's the best way to sharpen this uh
i don't know
i'm running out of time here running out
of time
i think i'll have to live with it
because i gotta finish
gotta finish uh what else
i mean we might not have time um let's
see okay so
let me check on one thing really quick
hmm
so we have about 30 minutes left
i want to show you what everyone else
did
um because we have i think 80 versions
of this thing i want to show you guys
like
the difference between
perfect ones between really good ones
between ones that are just okay and ones
that
kind of ended up in just this block out
version
um
so maybe i'll go for another
five or ten and then i'll hop in and
show you guys all
of these scanners from the community
it's really cool to see actually
okay
maybe we can bevel
the brackets
let's try that
okay
the brackets okay cool
so
let's see
i'll throw these into
subdivision surface as well
that turned into some putty i like that
all right
let's see if we can make some cuts yeah
the right cuts
correct cuts
so we need to sharpen up these edges
nice
nice
[Music]
nice
all right how this part will work i
don't know
uh-huh
mm-hmm
[Music]
i don't know if that's the best answer
but it is an answer
nice okay
oh we need to make some cuts here as
well we need to preserve this
see if we can't get some like beveled
edges on this side
so we could bevel this
we could bevel this how that corner is
gonna work i don't know
i want to bevel this this this
this this
basically just the contours of this
whole thing
yeah how that's gonna work i don't know
let's give this a shot
that's not bad
it's a quad at least so that's good
i'm gonna try there
so it still looks gummy
we need to sharpen it up
so let's see
about making some cuts there and there
ah okay so that start starts to get off
there
yeah this is where this is where it gets
tricky because i don't quite
know exactly
how this should go um especially these
corners too
i wonder if this could be done
or if that's just a big no-no who knows
this is where my modeling skills start
to fail me here
um
these ones are obvious
that's good
[Music]
wow that's this one's tough
it's going all over the place i wanted
to go here down down but i think because
this
isn't
because this is a triangle it's throwing
it off
but if i were to bevel this it would
throw that
that would just make another triangle
so i'm very
i'm stumped
here
i think this would require just a lot
more time getting in here and like
uh
tricky tricky
very tricky
yeah
really stumped on this
on these corners here
i don't quite understand
how to get those looking clean
with these bevels
very tough
[Music]
otherwise you know
just doing this
and it's certainly not the cleanest
yeah because that needs to continue
like this whole bottom piece needs a
thing
so tricky
so so tricky
ah this back is like
this back is rough
better but not the best
brutal
but not the worst
but not the worst
see what a little bit of octane looks
like
um
let us get to our camera view
boom
save it out
all right
okay uh not bad for nearly three hours
we got it blocked out we got a little
bit of detail in there
but this is no joke y'all this is no
joke
now that you saw
what i did in three hours let's see what
the community did
in
a week
six days roughly
let me show you guys this thing this is
really cool
let us open up
where is it
ah i know where it is i know exactly
where it is
uh
weekly challenge
boom boom
okay so these
this is everything
this is every scanner made by the entire
community
let's get it to let's switch things up
let's get to the the tech challenge
let's theme it up a little bit let's get
a little tech challenge uh
review going boom
yeah
sweet okay so this is every single one
made by the community
um we have
we've we've graded these right uh connor
ronan
mdk
um
they all hopped in to
the mod chat yesterday and they graded
every single one of these one by one and
labeled them from s tier
to a tier b tier and then participation
um and
also mdk put together this super cool
graphic let me save it out really quick
for you guys
and open this thing up
boom
this entire image right here
of all the different ones rendered out
thank you mbk for this that is amazing
all these different renders
s-class was hard to get it was really
hard to get
mdk one of the only two who got to
s-class of course you've been doing it
for 20 years
but that's the whole point guys it's a
technical challenge it's a very
difficult challenge
we see all these nice renders and we'll
get into this this will be uploaded to
the weekly challenge winners channel on
the discord server just in a little bit
here
so you guys can go in and find your name
and and see what rank you got and
everything
um
but let's hop in real quick and take a
look at these so
i zoom zoom in
look how look how nice this is both of
these so this is mdk and this is also
uh roman grass
apologies apologies
i butchered that these both um got the s
rank so congratulations to you guys
um
yeah mdk absolutely beautiful here
very clean you can kind of see the
difference here
and how you did this ah this is so nice
to see the answer
very very beautiful how you put this
together my goodness
so good
so so good
perfect hole cut out and everything wow
that's amazing
so nice
[Music]
let's see if we can't snap this to
center this up
yeah so you have these different modules
here
we didn't even get to this piece but
you put that together really nicely
wow
i know some of you guys had trouble on
the tape here but that looks really nice
it's snug and held closely to the actual
handle
really good stuff
this one is well hugged to the handle
yeah this one might need to be
subdivided once more perhaps
or pulled up a little bit more it could
also be the angle i'm viewing it now
let's see
yeah i also wonder if some of the
wireframes transferred over in fbx as
well
or the subdivision surface rather
but i love this i love that you like
took the
the time to do your extra little pieces
here these little hooks so instead of
doing holes you did an additive process
on that i thought that was really nice
these two are looking absolutely
beautiful and then we have the a tiers
these are these are darn close
these are really good really really
close and i wonder i'm i'm trying to see
here if i uh let me try reimporting this
and see
if
all ranks
subdivision surface uh so i guess they
didn't come with the subdivision surface
let's see if i subdivide this
look a little bit better
as well as this guy
yeah
yeah much better
much better much better
[Music]
same deal yeah much better i don't think
the subdivisions came with us so
a little tough a little tough
um
but you guys can see them all in this
beautiful image that i'd pulled up which
will be in the
weekly challenge winners to see them in
their full glory this will just give you
guys a brief kind of rough idea
these are the different a's
they're all kind of different shapes and
sizes it's cool to see they're not all
perfect
every single one of these is custom made
handmade
which makes every one of these very very
special i love that super cool and then
these are the bees
here let's see
these just need a little bit more work
maybe a bit more work on the shape of it
a bit more work on
cleaning up your geometry perhaps
and if you guys have any questions as to
why you got the rank that you got
um definitely hit up mdk or conor
on the server on the discord server link
below
and they can give you a nice description
of like what you guys need to work on
but these are looking really really nice
i just love that there's
almost 90 different versions of this
yeah you see this one's just shaped a
little bit differently it's still pretty
clean
but it is a technical challenge we're
trying to get close to the original 2d
concept as possible
and then we had the participation grade
which
for a number of reasons could be shape
this one might be shape
um could also be just like closer to a
blackout than a final
you see here less of a shape but again
it could be
the subdivision surface
whoa
it'll be near impossible for me to go
into all this
and add all the subdivision services uh
needed but y'all get the point
oh i like this i like this extra little
button thing that you had here it's cool
it's cool to see all the artists do this
in their own way
and i just love
let me pull up this image one more time
has it did i desktop it
where'd it go no no no no
wait where where the heck did i put it
yeah here we go
boom it's just so cool
to see all of these together rendered
out nicely like this
all these little gadgets and trinkets
so there's different um you guys can
also check your rank too on the server
in the uh
check my rank
you can go to the top
check your rank and you'll see how many
um
s a b
or p
points you have based off of
s rank a tier b tier or participation
tier and you guys will know but this
will also be posted up in the weekly
challenge winners server or uh channel
as well for you guys to see that
so that's pretty fun um
it was cool to do a technical challenge
for the first time
we did it because i was going away and
we wanted to
oh test test test
test test test
test this test
i'm going back
hello test test test test all right so i
guess my audio is back on this one
anyway um
thank you soto it's good to have you in
my ear that's why we got soto behind the
scenes setting things up let me know if
something's going wrong so i appreciate
that so
um yeah it was really fun doing this
technical challenge with you guys
it's very difficult modeling is very
very difficult especially to get it
precision nice and precise and accurate
to get your loop cuts nice and accurate
without any errors or glitches to get
your proportions correct but this is a
great way to train
to take something from 2d to 3d to
custom model something yourselves as
opposed to downloading an asset
i learned
quite a bit doing this i want to do more
this i want to finish this thing
and like i said at the beginning of the
stream you know we are
doing more of these technical challenges
is the first one
we'd like to try and do one once a month
and we want to start
catering these or not catering but um
theming these challenges and shaping
these weekly challenges
to better prepare you
for the new community challenge coming
up
in
a little bit
no announcement on that yet but it's
coming
so join the discord server hang out
there
um hop into these weekly challenges to
you know
to get ready get good
for the monthly challenge coming up soon
and um also guys subscribe if you ain't
subscribed already
um if you guys wanna uh
definitely subscribe if you aren't
subscribed already yeah that's i already
said it i appreciate you guys thank you
so much
um in the meantime
let's see if we can't
take
some
little q a with you guys y'all been
hanging out so you have any questions
i'm here with you guys let's switch back
and see if the audio is good
testing
no not seeing it
can you guys hear me
full screen
thumbs up if you guys can hear me full
screen
or thumbs down if you can't hear me
testing testing testing
um
so yeah i'm hanging out with y'all for
another five minutes or so
you guys have any questions
throw them my way thank you guys for
for doing this with me
that's a challenge for sure i thought i
could finish this whole thing on stream
no way
no way
craziness
wondrous you did your technical
challenge in 30 minutes
goodness
oh audio's fine thank you ronan i
appreciate you guys thank you thank you
thank you
but this scene has lower volume
interesting
interesting
um
so i have a stream in two weeks
trying to figure out what i should do if
you guys have any suggestions
i am open to it
um and then i have a pre-edited one
coming up
at the end of
of june i'm trying to figure out what
that video will be
um i'm considering doing a video on how
to make
windshield
or windscreen
or imperfections so if you're doing any
sort of car model you can drop that onto
your windshield and you'll have like
an accurate
windshield imperfection with like the
wipers and everything and like all the
dust and grime and bugs up in the
upper part you can just slap that
on your car models i'm wondering if that
will be
handy for you guys i'll make a pack
of something like that
it'd also be interesting to do spider
webs you could do like spider web alphas
i thought of a tutorial like that
and then you just do a little cloth
sim on it
it could be interesting
esperito with the upcoming challenge
require modeling as a complete noob to
3d modeling this challenge was difficult
but fun i'm i guess i'm asking if
there's a skill ceiling for the
challenge we want to keep the challenges
this is in general speaking right i want
to keep the challenges as attainable as
possible for as many artists as possible
so
if you're just starting out you can
still participate you don't have to like
model a character from scratch like this
last one infinite journeys was tough
because we had a character in the
foreground and character work is
extremely difficult
however like take
alternate realities for an example the
character is more in the mid ground
and it was more about the environment
and there's a lot of tools
and plugins and just free
free assets
that you guys can pull to make an
environment because unreal engine is
free kwiksel is free
with that alone you can do so much
blender is free of course
um
but for these challenges we want to keep
it as attainable as possible so
i think i can say
with
confidence
for now at least that
custom modeling is not required
i don't think custom auto link has
ever been required
unless dynamic machines counts as like i
mean the custom model stuff but
yeah we want to keep it as open as
possible and as attainable as possible
and and as as inspiring as possible for
the artists to step up to the plate and
like
do their best you know
um
it's a pyramid scheme where can one send
challenge ideas
[Music]
um
for like the infinite journeys challenge
uh
i don't know discord
discord is good
um usually yeah probably probably
discord is probably the best
let's see
uh especially no problem no problem at
all if you guys can just at me in the
chat it's a lot easier to see these
questions
mitch mitch hey man what's up maybe do a
quick video on modeling and rendering
and compositing that into real footage
something quick and easy
doable in a stream
that's a lot on a stream i've done
uh
deep dive videos like the robot tutorial
um it's kind of i kind of have two
videos that talk about what you're
talking about the first one is like
uh it's the one where i
model a pen
my headphones
my knife
and my water bottle i model all that
stuff i light it i render it
and have it look as beautiful as
possible
and then i have another video called how
to turn yourself into a robot and that
one
is me filming footage
tracking the footage
getting a 3d model from cg trader
bringing it into c4d
lighting it matching the lighting from
the footage to
the 3d scene
exporting and compositing so in both of
those videos you kind of get like
essentially what you're asking for
um
i did um
a stream where i made a hole in the
ground if you scroll back but also i
think the ultimate video the one you're
looking for
i realized i already did this apologies
all right so here's the real answer um i
have a video if you scroll down it's
called like
my full vfx workflow
and it's of a newspaper stand
and i model it texture it
uh
film footage track the footage
drop the 3d element into it match the
lighting between the footage
and the 3d scene
uh i render it composite it
export
and it's it's like a 55 minute long
video but it has everything for you
as everything you're asking
um
all right let's see what else you guys
got i see some
some mentions here
have i considered doing stuff like
visual content for the music industry
video jockeys and animators are in huge
demand in the edm not really
my like when it comes to 3d
my passion lies in creating 3d
environments that's my favorite thing to
do so
outside of that like i'm trying to write
a movie
you know i'm posting videos running this
channel so there's a lot i have going on
creating those kind of abstract
renders they're cool but i'd rather be
making environments to be honest
um
what would you do to make an fbx file
smaller uh
i don't know
delete unwanted stuff
try rendering out different versions of
an fbx i i personally don't know trying
obj
i don't know i don't think i have a good
answer for you i'm sorry
uh wondrous will there be something more
than a month-long challenge yes we are
planning
a
longer challenge than one month
and i can't wait to talk details about
it because we got some incredible ideas
stay tuned
um
why did i leave corridor did you watch
the video son you gotta watch the video
watch the video it's in the video
it's on corridor's channel watch the
video that's why i left i didn't lie the
truth is in the video
and there's no ill will
let's see what else
um any advice on taking that scary leap
in life okay i guess that's connected
uh
boy
it's kind of what
my the movie i'm writing is about
is taking that leap
um i mean
here here's what i'll say
if you're
working a job if you're doing something
that
either you don't enjoy or you foresee
not enjoying for whatever reason
and you're doing things in your spare
time that you love and you want to be
doing what you love as your job
i'd say keep doing the thing you love
doing in your spare time
that's number one
do it for long enough that you know
i love this and i can do this
and just try and do it a little bit more
and a little bit more and a little bit
more
until
you're let's just make it easy until
your full-time job
and your hobby right you're doing your
full-time job up here and you're doing
your hobby down here and you want your
hobby to be
the main thing right so just keep doing
this keep doing this right you have your
full-time job that's your stability okay
but keep doing this in your spare time
and try and build this up
even income wise if we're being specific
try and build this up
and find ways to get paid for doing what
you love
until
it starts to get close
to your full-time job salary
at a certain point you're going to have
to
drop off of this
to try and keep this up and you're going
to have to try and climb and climb and
climb and there's going to be this your
full-time job is this no rather your
full-time job is like this right
steady
consistent increase at your full-time
job in theory right
but then your your hobby right i guess
your hobbies going this way
and you want to try and build it up
right and when you switch to your hobby
now
you're making enough money that you can
pay your overhead you can pay your rent
you can pay for food et cetera et cetera
and maybe you have six months
worth of payment and overhead already in
savings okay
so if you stop if you left your
full-time job
and your hobby that that you're kind of
making money on already you're not just
jumping off into the abyss
if that just falls off
you at least have six months of a safety
net so you can work on this hobby to try
and build this hobby a little bit more
right to buy yourself more time
and
that's literally what i'm doing right
now is i'm trying
to make a living doing youtube
being creative trying to make a movie
right i'm trying to make a living doing
that and it's scary it's definitely
scary
because there is this
you know you don't know some some months
are bad some months are good
and it's and it can seem random and
appear random at times why things are
doing good or why the month is going bad
maybe it has to do with schools out
where school's back in
with youtube it's so fickle you don't
know if you're going to be getting a
certain amount of views i can't predict
the amount of views i'm going to get on
youtube
that's why patreon really helps because
at least it's like a locked in steady
thing you know like i know i can expect
this much per month
um gumroad helps a little bit you know
selling assets that helps a little
little bit
it's better than nothing
right
making views doing these streams helps
out certainly
um
but one thing i didn't mention is that
when you drop off so all of your time is
spent at your full-time job right and
then you have your hobby that you're
that you're you're you're like oh if i
had more time if i only had more time on
my hobby when you well when you drop off
your full-time job
which is the leap that you're talking
about very scary thing to do
but it's also very exciting because now
you have all this time to do what you
love and to build up what you love
so you're able to focus more on it on
the thing that you love and build that
up more
just make sure you like be smart be
smart about it have your at least six
months
of overhead into savings so that if
god forbid
you know life happens which it will
you at least have a backup
you know
so
best of luck to you is definitely
difficult and it's it's kind of tough
like talking about it in abstract but
um
yeah finding ways to make money
doing freelance work just let's say
we're all 3d artists right like we want
to do
freelance work and 3d work
as a way to
make money doing your hobby right
um for me the way i started
is first and foremost
first and foremost
do what you love
you're doing it in your spare time
already you guys know it right you guys
are doing what you love in your spare
time already so you're involved get
involved in the community
and you're doing it now you're on the
stream you're in the discord server
right
from there from my perspective when i
when i was much younger
i'm 30 right now
i started doing vfx in 2000
2006
like right when i started my youtube
channel right when i started my youtube
channel
um
and
i was doing it in my in my spare time
doing my hobby my spare time and
got to the point where i had met some
people i met some friends a community
like we all we're all getting to know
each other right there's the moderators
on the server there's all the people on
the server the community and the server
you guys are sharing ideas there's a job
offers channel on the server now you got
to be careful with that
right because you have some people who
just want a bunch of work for a little
bit of money but if you meet the right
people
and you develop the right relationships
they'll be people who will want
to pay you for your services to do
things and then if you do do a good job
and you enjoyed them and you thought
that they paid well and they matched
what you were worth you guys keep
working together
i remember my first client joe cornell
at synapse effects
and i did uh
you know i did like website stuff for
him i helped him with like website
graphics i helped him with his cause he
had clients and he didn't
he had too many clients and he needed to
outsource some work so that's where i
came around and i only knew about him we
met because i tried to like
um synapse effects is a like blood and
gore pyrotechnic one-stop shop for
special effects and when i was doing
cardboard warfare i needed some fake
blood and my friend told my friend who i
was also a filmmaker we played video
games together he told me about this
website synapsefx if you sign up they'll
give you a little fake bottle of blood
he'll send it to you and
that's how i met joe and joe was like
dude you're making cool
stuff i have these clients i need work
done can you do work i said yes
absolutely i worked with him for years
he was my first like the first guy to
pay me for all this stuff
um
you know and then i started selling
uh textures and doing tutorials on
cgtutts.com
i think was the name of the website
and i would upload
texture packs i would make my own
textures it was like 200 bucks for x
amount of textures and i would do these
different packs and i'd get paid for
tutorials
so just keep doing what you love find
ways to make money doing it
see if you can keep that up in your
spare time and get that close to your
full-time salary it's tough because
full-time salary
that you know could pay really well you
could also have a bunch of benefits too
health insurance 401k
a pension maybe even right
and those are things that make staying
in a full-time job very enticing and
very very difficult to leave
but at a certain point
what's
worth more
the money you're making
or your your happiness
now ideally you could be doing both
but if you had to choose would you
rather be living a happy life
and
making barely enough money to survive
or
would you rather
be making a ton of money but be
miserable doing what you love
so it's a tough one yeah it's a tough
one and yeah that's kind of what my
movie is about a little a little bit
they're a theme that theme is there
throughout the movie so it's a good like
inspirational
fun
kind of thing so i can't wait to get
more into the movie and talk about it
with y'all but i hope that helps i went
i went super deep with that i think
that's all the time i have
for today
um
i really appreciate you guys thank you
for
for stopping by and joining me
thanks for watching me model thanks for
modeling with me
and
uh check out the discord server we got
the weekly challenges popping off so hop
on over
i think that's
everything think that's everything you
guys are amazing thank you so much
i'll see you next time
uh not next week but the week after i'll
be doing another live stream with you
all we'll figure out what that's going
to be all right until next time peace
out y'all be good later
[Music]
i